you've been bitten and oh oh it's
venomous how long have you got well that
depends on a few factors including the
potency dose delivered and speed of
distribution turns out not all Venom's
act the same way here are the animals
with the fastest acting venom on earth
first up spiders there are around 40,000
species of spider and most are venomous
but thankfully only a handful pose a
threat to humans including the male
Sydney funnel-web spider its venom is 60
times as potent as cyanide and can kill
a human in one to two hours
the venom attacks the nervous system
kicking it into overdrive
until ultimately it shuts down of course
spiders aren't the only venomous animals
in Australia it's home to 20 of the
world's 25 deadliest snakes including
the Eastern brown snake which is
responsible for the most snakebite
deaths in the country its venom is eight
thousand times stronger than cyanide and
can kill a human in about one hour its
venom also attacks the central nervous
system but this time it slows everything
down and to top it off the venom has a
coagulant that causes the blood in your
veins and arteries to clot between the
two it's not a good way to go
now at this point you might consider
switching your Australian safari to a
scuba dive just to be on the safe side
but venomous animals live in Australian
waters too like the blue ringed octopus
its venom is 1,000 times more toxic than
cyanide and it'll bring down a human in
just 20 to 40 minutes bacteria in its
saliva makes an extremely potent
neurotoxin which paralyzes your muscles
and once that paralysis hits your
diaphragm and rib muscles you have only
a few minutes before you suffocate to
death but another marine animal is even
deadlier the fastest acting venom on
earth belongs to the Australian box
jellyfish or sea wasp it's not the most
potent venom out there at 2,000 times
stronger than cyanide but encounter one
of these guys and you'll be dead in 15
minutes that's because their tentacles
are covered with tiny venom loaded darts
called the mad assists which shoot
heart-stopping toxins into the body
wherever they make contact all of this
sounds pretty scary but remember you're
less likely to die by venomous spider
then by car crashes and infection or
disease and it's not like these animals
are after you anyway they've just as
well prefer that you stick to your own
habitat but still be smart be respectful
be safe tell us the scariest animal
encounter you've ever had and thanks for
watching